foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ghost you are danger close to the Zone
this arrow is going to pack a punch copy
approved
Sunday all stations Shadow one missile
is ready for immediate delivery standby
for launch es in Target
missile in blue
[Music]
[ __ ] you
direct Target destroyed
following the U.S missile strike that
kills alcatala leader General gulbrani
during an arms deal in El mazara his
second in command Hassan zayani assumes
the mantle of leadership in Val's
Revenge teaming up with an international
drug cartel
several months pass and Hassan's
activities have gained the attention of
General Shepherd and CIA station Chief
Kate leswell ordering the deployment of
Marines led by the lieutenant ghost
Riley and Sergeant John soaked with
tevish to apprehend Hassan in al-mazra
however Hassan has already fled the area
and now ghost and soap have discovered
that it was in possession of an
American-made ballistic missile
what the [ __ ] is this
it's all in English
and they stick missiles some mobile
launcher these will go A Thousand Miles
yeah at least how the hell did Orion get
their hands on this
7-6 gets through to Laswell Roger
standby bravo 7-6 charlie to watch her
one how copy this is what you're once in
traffic last well this is Ghost we got
something
tell me you found her son ghost
take a look at this
ghost do you have a son negative we
found a weapons cache asan's got
missiles
they're American
this is Gold Eagle actual repeat your
last I'll say again a song as American
missiles
well continuing their hunt for Hassan
leswell Captain John price and Sergeant
Kyle Gaz Garrick pursue one of Hassan's
couriers in Amsterdam learning that
Hassan has allied with the Las Almas
cartel and is being sheltered in Mexico
after a failed attempt to apprehend
Hassan Mexican Special Forces Colonel
Alejandro Vargas and his second in
command sergeant major Rodolfo Parra
participate in a joint operation with
ghost soap and Philip Graves PMC Shadow
company to capture Hassan
while they were successful and finally
catching up to them they are forced to
release him from captivity to avoid
political Fallout
however they did manage to place a
tracking device on a cell phone
Hassan was tracked to Spain with price
leswell and Gaz would launch a raid on a
Las Almas owned fishing Hatchery there
they discover that Las Almas have
obtained russian-made GPS devices to use
with a stolen U.S missiles
but before they're able to work with
this new information leswell has
suddenly captured by alcatala forces
[Music]
this is a proof of life
where did this come from
no
points and Ace likely to our they go
underground there will Lucifer good
we'll leave the rescue too that's not
gonna happen John
say again General
this is a
September let's win since now
preparation things take violence and
timing I can do both Kate's life is in a
[ __ ] hourglass
I know you're upset
this happened on your mission and that's
a tough build a swaddle
you said to me we leave them I'm telling
you I can't help you but I won't stop
you
I love her back in 12 hours
okay with your friend
about friends
it's about the enemies
good luck
we'll be going head-to-head with AQ on
the hotel we're gonna have hundreds more
protection last one we're needing up all
right give us an army
with the help of Nikolai and Farah along
with her Freedom Fighters they were able
to take on the alcatala Convoy in
uzikstan and break her free
while this is happening Alejandro and
soap infiltrate a last alamas meeting to
identify their leader al-sonombre who
turns out to be Alejandro's former
teammate baleria
Valeria makes a deal with Shadow company
she would provide the location of the
missiles and when they return where they
can find Hassan
ghost briefs Shadow Company soap and
Alejandro lead a raid on an abandoned
offshore oil rig and cargo tanker
it was successful in locating the
missile but too late to stop the launch
sequence however with seconds to spare
they were able to change the target
but on their way back to base they would
find out that there has been a change of
plans
and a general Shepherd's order Braves
and Shadow company have turned their
back on Alejandro and task force one for
one and taking control of their base of
operations
[Music]
[Applause]
what's this
this is the immediate Fusion step away
from the gate
what you heard me are you crazy
this is my base not a base this is a
sizable Cobra facility
and I admire it
so I'm taking
you boys have been relieved thank you
for your service I don't know I don't
take orders from you
in Valeria say that
now that makes me wonder what else I
don't know about your affiliation with a
drug lord
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me
penduline griefs don't do that don't
do that no one needs to get hurt here
are you threatening US soldier I don't
make threats
I make guarantees so let's not do this
I'm calling Shepherd General Shepherd
sends his regards
he told me all wouldn't take this well
he knows about this
he's put me in command of this operation
from here on out so you all need to
stand down it's time to let the pros
finish this
why the hell are we talking like this is
some kind of negotiation it's not
I've got my orders and now you have
yours and who the [ __ ] do you think you
are cabron
my men are inside
I'm afraid not
your men have been
detained
the
[ __ ]
[Applause]
let's go Johnny get out of there so go
[Music]
[Applause]
there ghosts
that was a big mistake brother
did not have to be like this
thank you
son of a [ __ ]
find him
[Music]
with help from leswell price and gas
ghost and soap launch an attack to free
Alejandro and his soldiers
following the successful raid lazor
reveals that back in August Shepard and
Graves were responsible for a failed
Transportation mission that led to the
three ballistic missiles being stolen
and since then they've been doing their
best to cover it up
price confronts ship it regarding this
news he then promises to pursue them
once Hassan and Graves have been
eliminated
Task Force 141 and the Mexican Special
Forces allies succeed in killing Graves
they would then find out from Valeria
that Hassan is in Chicago intending to
fire the last remaining missile onto
Washington DC
fortunately the team arrives just in the
nick of time and after fighting through
the hordes of hostiles occupying the
high-rise they managed to put a stop to
the missile strike and come face to face
with Hassan
[Applause]
all right
you broken I'm good go you got this
stop let's move that car won't roll get
down
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ghost soap
watch the window
attacking
wheel aren't fading
[Music]
perfect show LT
you called it Sergeant
all stations
Assad's down enemy Kia
now that the mission is complete Task
Force 141 and leswell meet up in a bar
leswell confirms that General Shepherd
has vanished Without a Trace but also
says that she's been digging into more
information about Russian involvement in
the missile Heist price insists that
it's over but Laswell proves that they
are now working with someone new
she passes around a picture of her main
lead
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
who is he
Makarov
[Music]
[Music]
IC
beef chicken or fish gentlemen salad
space
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]